so you open
your new book discussing rogue planet
pso j318 i never said this out loud
0.522 so a rogue planet which
is just this poetic beautiful vision of
a planet that um that as you write
lurches across the galaxy like a
rudderless ship
wrapped in perpetual darkness it's
surface swept by constant storms
as black skies raining molten iron
just like the vision of that the scary
the
the darkness the
just how not pleasant it is for human
life
just the intensity of that metaphor i
don't know
and the reason you use that
is to paint in a feeling of
loneliness and despair
and um
why maybe on the planet side
why does it feel maybe it's just me why
does it feel so profoundly lonely on
that kind of planet
like what uh like what
i think it's because we all want to be a
part of something a part of a family
or a part of a community or
a part of something and so our solar
system and by the way
i only it's sort of like a
like when you treat yourself to like
eating an entire tub of ice cream
like i sometimes treat myself to imagine
things like this and not just be so cut
and dried
but when you imagine that this planet's
not because i don't want to give
emotions to a planet per se but the
planet's not part of anything
it's somehow probably um it's just all
on its own just kind of out there
without that warm
energy from its sun it's just all alone
out there
to me it was a little discovery that i
actually feel pretty good at
being part of this solar system it felt
like we have a sun
we have like a little family yeah and it
felt like it
sucked for the rogue planet yeah to just
floating about uh
not floating of flying uh rudderless
by the way how many rogue planets are
there
in your sun we don't know totally i mean
there's some rogue planets
that are just born on their own i know
that sounds really weird to be how can
you be born an orphan
but they just are because most planets
are born
out of a disk of gas and dust around a
star
but some of these small planets are like
totally failed stars they're so failed
they're just small planets on their own
but we think that there's probably
honestly there's another path to a rogue
planet
that's one that's been kicked out of its
star system by other planets
like a game of billiard balls something
just gets kicked out
and we actually think there's probably
as many rogue planets as stars
no flying out there um fundamentally
alone
you